[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us mr chad miatay
[Applause]
we were talking about this mildly i
think a few weeks back and uh i'm still
curious about it what's the biggest
amount of money that you guys have
declined over a job
over any kind of work that you just said
like no i'm not gonna do it that's easy
for me what's that what's that so
verizon hit me up to do a promotional
video about facing your fears and i had
to jump out of a plane i was offered
twenty five thousand dollars i said no
that's all you do is skydiving because
you have to stay awake
yeah that was gonna pass out oh you mean
you wanted to take a sediment i get
vertigo
so i didn't think that i would be able
to stay awake because if i pass out and
i'm a big guy it's an issue so they're
like you have to stay awake and i'm like
so you can't tandem jump with another
dude they're going to tandem jump with
you but i'm at that time i was almost
300 pounds ain't nobody doing that for
25 dollars dude you need like four extra
parachutes probably
number one i need i need you to take off
your shirt right now
hey
have you guys ever seen a [ __ ] polar
bear just sit on an ice cube that's what
it is
with no fur
[ __ ] like the meme [ __ ] i was going
through you know youtube will suggest
videos every now and then just give me
80 days and it was the hawaii video and
i'm looking at this video i'm like who's
this fat [ __ ] in this video and it's
this guy i didn't realize how much
weight he gained
i've never been able to call somebody
else
shut the [ __ ] up you walked in last time
[ __ ] hot and you're like aunt you
were fat
that's different
you're confusing things right now it
wasn't the fact that you were fat that
was the the topic it was that you were
fat and ugly because you can't be
fat and ugly you're a very good looking
skinny guy but when you how's joondi in
hawaii going it's going great actually
fantastic but let me go back to that
when you get fat you look like a child
that would have been left and chopped
and never picked up
that's what you look like right now hey
let me tell you this right now i was
left in china
hey me too there we go
i love that nick put his hand around
nobody high five
that was the air force roll photo
he's yeah
when did you see him fat i saw this
random photo popped up google searched
it was like who's this [ __ ] back
order cut
this whole dancing just really chubby
and i started dying laughing by myself
that was great but you look great now
you also he looks because when he gets
through all the songs had his stages
that's true he still looks the same but
when you got big you were unrecognizable
are you
[Laughter]
the ugly house yeah the thatch you doing
thing where you used you to illustrate
his point i hate how brilliant you are
that's all
it's disgustingly brilliant that's all
found footage you look great now
speaking of jobs you declined i think
the biggest one that i and maybe this
one was the same as bar but we both did
an audition for in living color
they're bringing it back it's probably
like twenty twenty eleven maybe twenty
both [ __ ] nailed it and um the
wayne's brothers wanted both of us on
and during that time they were offering
about what was it like 15 grand a show
it was like 15 grand an episode an
episode for the first season guaranteed
13 episodes or something so then
depending on how many episodes were on
but they said that they liked us so much
i thought they would only be room for
one asian but then they picked us both
showed pilot tanked after that didn't
[ __ ] reshoot it they hated the talent
on there and we decided to keep jk
because at the time they saw youtube as
a competition so they was like you guys
gotta quit your youtube your jk film
[ __ ] we don't want that [ __ ] on there
you guys got to come a part of the in
living color brand and i'm like dude
that's a big [ __ ] deal but we have
this team
which most of them aren't even with us
anymore
what the [ __ ]
is what i'm saying in the moment i was
loyal to that [ __ ] no it never went
through anyway right yeah the crazy
thing is the juxtaposition so like this
is during a time where we're still doing
like you know those asian shows
so we were coming back we we got [ __ ]
like five scripts that we had to
memorize because we were flying directly
in to get the audition from a college
asian show yeah and if so we're like
[ __ ] we're trying to memorize on the
plane try to pull all-nighter we get
there and then we see all the other
comedians that were like uh performing
during that time like you would like
katie tatara like
at the lab factory improv whatever right
so we're like oh [ __ ] we're going up
against actual stand-up comedians in the
casting room then we see keenan wayne
walk by and we're like oh [ __ ] this
motherfucker's here so we hear from the
casting director uh because they're
missing a couple of like key parts he's
directly involved in casting this time
so me and joe are [ __ ] [ __ ]
bricks pacing out it was my first
audition i never had an audition
we're shooting bricks outside of the uh
the audition room and then the [ __ ]
lady comes out you know what he just
wants to see everyone improv so all the
stuff we've been [ __ ] memorizing
we're like we're just gonna [ __ ]
throw this [ __ ] out the window
and uh we both did our audition and i
think both me and joe made and he had
not only him he had his family there so
that he wanted to see like if his kids
could laugh so both me and joe made him
and his family laugh
and then that's when the casting
director called us the next week they
said uh we got it and then so we had to
go all of a sudden to like some
high-rise like um la like lawyer
entertainment lawyer person that person
like represented i don't know like the
[ __ ] twilight people because they're
the biggest at the time
and they showed us the contract from fox
and it was yeah 15 grand an episode
guaranteed 30 uh 13 episodes possibly
eight seasons we're just looking at it
just doing the numbers like wow this is
[ __ ] crazy because it was like
there was like 300 g's when our youtube
channel was making like four grand you
know we're like oh this is [ __ ] crazy
and we really got to talk this out so we
go back to
uh our house which is where we're
working out so that that's the
juxtaposition like going on to into
beverly hills to me to our office in the
living room
living room good old days with our
[ __ ] free interns what should we do
guys
[Laughter]
[ __ ] entertainment console for his tv
with cinderblocks
you know what this dog would piss on all
the time
we are so poor
it was it was because this one was
trying to be an industrial look
like he was trying to be artistic so
this food went to home depot bought
cinder blocks and a plywood because he
thought that [ __ ] was like oh i got the
[ __ ] art walk look you know yeah
chipotle
yeah yeah i think the funniest part when
i saw his dog pee on it that [ __ ] killed
me dude he goes hey did i take my old tv
console and literally his dog tries it
all the time starts pissing on it as he
showing me the console i cried london
because it's a raw cinder block you just
soaks it yeah it soaks it and you see
the pea traveled up the cinder block
right like the wet it's so funny it
soaks into it
[Laughter]
god we were so poor but yeah so we
kissed and we so we kissed but we were
saying
yeah we were so loyal and then fox was
like they didn't see youtube as a
benefit they saw it as uh
competition they saw it as threats so
they're like you have to shut your
youtube channel down for like seven
years or some [ __ ] like that so mirrors
are like [ __ ] i don't know about that
but then it was 300 g's which is an
enormous amount of money to us at the
time and then so we ended up uh saying
no they shot their first season i guess
keenan wasn't happy with this so never
even aired damn they didn't like the
talent that they had and we would have
been shut down for seven years if oh it
would have still oh yeah
that was crazy to like audition in front
of like one of your idols and there
wasn't like a signing bonus where like
oh even if the show doesn't go you still
get this they would have guaranteed
mitchell barely [ __ ] knew how to read
back then i don't know
that's true i just learned how to read
like a like a year prior well signing at
the top like the [ __ ] news
i don't know how to read
if they took your channel they would
have guaranteed money for sure there's
no way absolutely not back then nah they
[ __ ] treated entertainers like a
bunch of [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] they're
like you're lucky to lick my boots so
this is how crazy it was um
no one had our number we didn't get any
contacts from anyone in hollywood right
the minute we they heard that we're
gonna be on the show not even like
officially we started getting phone
calls from [ __ ] everywhere wme caa
all this crazy [ __ ] right so we had a
meeting at caa we go there and there's
like hey i'm a booking agent oh i'm at
this agent so we're me like eight agents
everyone's all happy sitting in this big
conference room
then this guy walks in he sits on this
oh [ __ ] that guy with no shoes yeah he
comes in sits like this with [ __ ]
highlights in the hair and he goes so
who are these guys and then they're like
oh they're uh upcoming youtubers they're
like thank you and he just walks
and then now it's left to the other like
junior agents to clean that [ __ ] up
we'll be in contact we'll be in contact
we'll definitely contact you and uh
we'll see you later exactly how it is
yeah and we're like
oh what's up guys [ __ ] this one started
blasting him on site
y'all didn't know why i'm bang though
did you homie it is 10 a.r.s
today's video is brought to you by
upstart saying goodbye to high interest
credit card debt is one of the first
steps towards financial independence but
the interest month after month can feel
like you're never ending hamster wheel
and that's where upstart comes in
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay off high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you're more than just your credit
score so rather than just looking at
your credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors such as your
income employment and other information
provided in the loan application to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you
could check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to up to 50 000
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com off the record that's
upstart.com off the record to check your
rate today and don't forget to use our
url to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined by your
income credit and certain other
information that you put on your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record back in those days yeah because
in in the future we went back to pitch
shows completely [ __ ] different tone
but but that was like the beginning of
the
year
west yeah it was like that for a very
long time though like even before that
before i did my my uh the film [ __ ]
i did that film because i couldn't get a
um i couldn't get casted at any agency
unless they wanted to keep me for new
media so they said oh you can't act i
was like
oh i can't act [ __ ]
so i made this [ __ ] movie but we got
this digital product yeah exactly so
literally you do that film it goes to
sundance every [ __ ] agent in
hollywood will knock in my door and
they're like oh i was like i had a
meeting with you dude you said i wasn't
good enough but see that's like the
weird thing you just have to show these
people what they're missing how do they
get your number out or nowhere else i
don't know they were at my house
they straight called your address not
your number they got your chest i get
phone calls they're like hey i'm
whatever tony tran from caa whatever the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
who turned you down recently
yeah you got something yeah i mean
probably the most amount of money we
turned down was as periodics we turned
down the vegas show at cosmopolitan when
they were first opening oh [ __ ] wait you
mean like a residency yeah how much
i don't remember so you guys could have
been like the jabberwocky show yes yes
so at that time i'm so mad at poriyati i
know we're [ __ ] dumbasses but at that
time
at that time yeah constant pollen hit a
set and they're like yeah we want a show
a vegas show because we're opening up
this place called cosmopolitan and you
guys would like be a show to rival the
jabberwockies and we're like ah they're
the homies we don't really want to rival
them and at that time we were about like
20 21 year olds yeah so nine worst
business decisions worst business
decision and at that time we were
traveling the world we're going to
germany we're going to russia we're just
like hella traveling you guys want a
[ __ ] huh yeah you don't want helen a
[ __ ]
[Music]
we wanted to overseas
and at that time yeah we were just like
traveling it's like do you want to stay
locked down or do you want to travel
and now that i look back and i was like
damn i should have stayed longer i just
pictured you sitting there and then two
thought bubbles one was a lot of cash
and another one was naked [ __ ] and
you went pop
what was the what was the deciding
factor with saying no to that well i
mean other than like
half the team wasn't 21 yet so we didn't
know what vegas was like and we didn't
see it and we didn't see what money was
disappointing and we were just like yeah
we're a bunch of 19 or 20 year olds
traveling the world that was something
too because i remember what that
ballpark number was do you remember what
that ballpark number was
30 million
something like that we would end up like
that yeah
we'd probably still be there
yeah
but hey look at the price sign you're
here now baby
look at the bright side
[Laughter]
you said you shot a pilot yeah because
at the same time we were also shooting
like a possible reality tv show with
like wayne brady oh and so that was
going to go hand in hand with it and i
think he just freestyles asian jokes at
you guys a little bit
yeah [ __ ] dance though
yeah
he's cool
yeah he's great i remember i was so
jealous of dancers back in the day
because i remember like telling bar like
man it was so
well because one uh well i mean
comedians we have a longer lifespan of
uh careers so i'm not jealous about that
but when it comes down to it
but when it comes back
in my youth
you guys were traveling to all the cool
countries with all the hottest girls
because language was dance and physical
you know what i mean so you get the
[ __ ] tango and [ __ ] where it's like
we we're stuck at the asian shows at the
asian club in [ __ ] english-speaking
universities with these [ __ ] nerds
and [ __ ] hey shout out to the kids who
brought us up all right
shout outs we need your money still for
the fundraisers you guys held to pay for
it and thank you for showing me the best
chinese restaurant in your city every
single time
dorm it's the worst chinese food ever
dude i just did a bad spot and i'm like
bro you live out in wichita
i don't think your chinese food here is
good it's always like that
like just the best dinner in ithaca
but dancers are going a [ __ ] what
russia brazil all these places with the
hottest women russia's really dope right
now i think that's the caveat is as a
dancer you can also latch on to a music
artist's benefit as well which is hard
now like our career got [ __ ] super uh
lengthened from being attached to lmfao
it got the lifespan [ __ ] got
stretched yeah but that wasn't really us
you know like it's you got an
opportunity from red yes how did that
happen
i mean that was just almost like half
luck half opportunity you didn't say nah
bro we're dancing no it's it's like
it literally came from making the
judgment call you know sometimes when
you're doing work there's a chance to do
something for free that's gonna suck but
could open up a door it's like that we
said there's a good opportunity yeah
because we we were doing uh abdc and we
used their song and that was like the
first time that lmfo's music got
featured on mtv as like uh someone was
performing to it so they were watching
it we didn't know that but then we go to
wango tango to just be we were like a
b-side throw away outside of the gate
performance in this small-ass stage and
then as we were there uh this other
artist named mad khan who did the remix
of beggin back then he was on his way in
and he was like an opener of the inside
show at the actual stadium and he goes
hey i don't have no one on my team like
would you guys want to come in and just
do a dance because i got like there's no
crowd and i just want more people on
stage and that was the judgment call of
like do we just do this real quick for
nothing everything you'd be like what
are you gonna pay me [ __ ] no
yeah because because the the exchange
was it would get us into the real stage
we were like let's [ __ ] do it so we
did it i think didn't we perform toronto
mad khan song on the show too yeah we
did but i mean it was a popular break-in
song like by far so we go in and we're
in the we're now in the main stadium
which we didn't even have access to and
then there we run into lmfao and then
they go they were like yo you're the
guys that use our [ __ ] and we were like
we're gonna sue you yeah
yeah you used our [ __ ] up [ __ ]
here's the paperwork it's for me for
free or here's the paperwork
you're a question
so we just were like tripping out that
they even saw it and we had a cool
conversation took a photo
didn't have any discussion about working
together at all and then uh by chance
this fool runs into them two other times
by total coincidence just randomly it's
like um in life like a movie theater or
what i forget what the other time was
and then i think it was nice that we
were both coming up together you know we
did the tv show and they they were
getting their heads with a little john
and stuff and
i think we were just talking about oh it
would be great we don't know how but you
know let's do something together
and so a lot of the quest members
started working with lmfao at their live
shows it was all kind of like in one big
bang because we were always talking
about it with them and then they go hey
let's do a dance thing of some sort and
then out of nowhere they we were just
fresh on their minds because he kept
running into them and then uh lmfo hits
him up and goes hey we got an idea for a
dance thing uh maybe it's like a shuffle
thing and they sent the song and it was
every day i'm shuffling we were like
what the [ __ ] this is a banger yeah that
was coco actually that was the first
thing we did with them yeah
was uh ragnan and it was like the
biggest at first when um so it was
their wardrobe stylist coco that sent me
the track and at first i was like this
sucks it's horrible you know
you hated it you liked it
way different from this one
this was like
mind-blowing
and then i think though also i came from
a mindset of you know they wanted to do
shuffling and back then you know we come
from like a
battle background and making all these
shows and we wanted to do something new
and different that people couldn't do so
to make something that everyone could do
it's like what
what's the value in that what's the
point you know oh you're too [ __ ]
artiste man we were classic people
inclusivity
but then it's like you start realizing
it's like oh if you can actually make
something and everyone could potentially
have fun and you're stopping it like
who's the [ __ ] bad guy in this you
know so it's like tick tock like all
these tick tock dances people enjoy it
because everybody can do exactly so it's
like okay let's let's do it and see how
it goes and yeah we had no idea it was
going to help us as much as it did the
thing we never told anybody though is
that uh we were we were good at
shuffling already because we were
[ __ ] making fun of it
before practice like [ __ ] around
that's half the dance community we would
do it ironically all the time to just
clown on it and then when they were like
oh we're gonna do it for real we were
like okay sure we're ready
so like that the whole music video we're
doing it we want to crack up at
ourselves practically yeah all over us
layman's are like how cool
all of us were like wow i'm trying to
practice it i couldn't do it i can't
show you the whole time we're like
[ __ ] sentences yeah
even when the video first came out i was
in korea at the time and i called him
from korea and be like did you watch it
yeah it's like damn it sucks
let's see that's crazy though like you
guys won the vma awards no is that it's
because you beat us
[Laughter]
that was really good that was really
good yeah that was good oh it hash it
out now dude all right get it all out
did you guys get to go to the vma
because of that yeah we did wow see
that's cool sick man you guys weren't
yeah we were there for that yeah yeah i
thought so you guys ever look back and
kind of see like how crazy your life is
because of dance because dance wasn't
like this before like especially money
opportunities it's so [ __ ] nuts
because this was this was the career
that everybody's like you do this on the
side for your fun [ __ ] you're not going
to make a career out of this and then
you guys literally made this into a
business which blows my [ __ ] mind
yeah and yet we still [ __ ] ended up
here no
we went like this and then went like
this listen come on you went from bmas
to jk news you're gonna be like yeah
yeah that was the most hybrid
when you say it like that it doesn't
sound so bad
you